you said you're never going to step a
foot in texas again i know this is
unexpected oh nothing with you is
unexpected
your last job is over 17 years ago
that's quite a gap well you know i've
worked almost every day for the last 17
years i moved back in with my wife last
week don't call him the cops
really hey we decided to make a run of
it i just need a place to crash for a
couple of days what's the big deal nike
go [ __ ] yourself all right look i'm
gonna be straight with you i'm an adult
film actor
excuse me
so why are you back mr hollywood mikey
welcome back dude i'm on top of my game
right now on like every single possible
level physical stamina my mind is sharp
i'm taking 5 htp for serotonin in my
brain yeah do with my skill and ability
there's no denying what i can do the
universe is on my side bro before long
it'll be like we're still married
we are still married
i'm doing this tonight you're probably
gonna start to find what's your name
everybody calls me strawberry you're
like a extraterrestrial around here and
[ __ ] with me
not i
loved you where were you this cute
little town called none of your [ __ ]
business texas hope you had a good
[ __ ] time
now it's time to leave
i think it's cool you just said [ __ ] it
i'm gonna get paid for doing the thing i
love most
and as long as you're not hurting
anybody
you do you man
i'm not afraid to fight you i don't give
a [ __ ]
he [ __ ] punched me i would 100 out
cardio that guy ah sorry for swearing
the [ __ ] got out of control
i came this [ __ ] close to getting
shot
this [ __ ] close
the dog's like oh he's a good man i can
tell by his nice energy
your persona
life's sweet sophie
life is sweet
[Music]
[Music]